jan congratulations on your win you
seemed unhappy that you had a few games
where you didn't play a lot of chess a
couple theoretical draws it seems that
you got your workout in today yeah after
five consecutive first days yeah
okay not completely raised days but sort
of yeah like not not toughest you know
they
in the office
yeah it was
i mean the pleasant surprise that left
decided to go to queen c2c5 line which
is very very complex and
i think there is not some not so much to
uh despite some like correspondence
games
and
yeah probably he wasn't quite
quite aware of what was going on but
yeah
he played this move knight bd2 early in
the opening did it surprise you
somehow i thought that knight c3's
principle or in other ways something
might not be the twin maybe then before
uh and maybe the aj queen b3 is not so
is also about itself but
as far as i remember it should be
combined with the knight on c3 somehow
right because then you go knight you do
bishop f4 or something let me just put
that and this is like i mean okay very
complex but uh
i mean just just just would be a i don't
know a big fight but i think the way uh
the way he played was a little bit
clumsy
and pieces wasn't really well
coordinated and uh yeah in fact i could
play five probably even my mo one move
earlier because
yeah room to do an a5 immediately yes
yeah after knight to one maybe maybe
five made much more sense than you know
than h6 but i thought okay h6 maybe not
spoiling anything yeah no not at all
yeah so it's still like very complex and
somehow after a five black souls you
know the problem of developing there uh
the queen's side without like touching
your queen yes so for example like queen
c8 would be fine but then okay knight h4
f3 and white gets a lot of tempi so
that's important like to
to be tricky and
there is always like some move like b6
it exists but then
probably the idea of knight five becomes
very easy for white because the pawn is
no more i mean pawn is not hanging it's
not bound you know he's not existing
anymore yeah right on c5 yeah so you get
to this position it seems like a very
clear advantage over here and he decides
to shed a couple of pawns
well i i actually don't know what like
what was his like uh intentions but i
think the position is practically
uh i wouldn't like maybe like lost just
like a little you know a little bit of
strong term but uh i mean it's it's very
tough to play here with white because
i mean okay i have one outpost on e4
another outpost on d4 and it's you know
it's more or less uh a question which
you know which pawn are you going to
to give give away some probably 95
doesn't work due to knight jc5 yes
instead of knight g3 uh sorry yeah
position 95 in 95 i mean okay besides
the the fact that d1 is hanging uh also
like something like knight c5 always
like always when something looks like
crushing so here i was like more or less
sure i'm like
i mean have a completely dominant
position okay and here well i maybe i
could play something like bishop e3 uh
yeah okay g3 is like strategically lost
or something yeah so if queen e3 i could
start with queen d4 also but here i felt
like okay maybe bishop c3 queen c5
knight e5 uh rook f8 for example and
then g4
and well at the end of the day his
pieces are not so bad yes he has all
pieces into the play so maybe okay this
is just completely uncalled for to to
take such risk as black because
i mean after what i did it should be
like
uh you know a routinely winning position
but at that moment uh as they say like
brain exists stopped working there
i mean so i ended up calculating okay
rejuvenative knight c5 and i more or
less you know expected some resignation
here right uh but as well any bucharest
uh
and then i also expected the resignation
uh yeah suddenly he started like playing
i don't know if he played well but uh
yeah clearly uh
here i could you know
spend you know a minute to two
minutes or two more like calculating but
since uh brain wasn't working at all i
just ended up like playing dd5 d4 and of
course i miscalculated because after
bishop before
my intention was to play knight c3 this
one right here yeah bishop c3 takes
takes on d7
uh so probably i take i'm okay my plan
was to take with your rook so i quickly
find rook d1 check yes so that's why
bishop a2
k7 green takes c5 and queen just ah yeah
rugby one king h2 and here queen g5
doesn't work because of bishop f7
and queen g6 doesn't work uh because of
uh g4
queen g4 and rookie three
and once i managed i mean once i found
out that uh
there is some some surprise like rookie
freeze arranging me okay maybe
i wouldn't be surprised if hero king
computers are just something but it
looks like i have to like to to go for a
droid queen h4 and you're down a piece
oh okay that's uh you know that's not a
big deal you know if i deliver a mate
then i you know i can live without a
piece here for foreign but probably i
don't deliver anything
and here uh okay probably i started
calculating some lines again but uh
it wasn't you know my brightest
achievement when did you start getting
worried about your position
uh i would say after we missed g4 so
default i mean okay instead of
okay let's say instead of first of all
instead of 96 you can play 96 if you
just want to give away a pawn like one
pawn you give away and you just i mean
this should be completely winning
because okay i actually just have to
connect the passage past the pawns
but i decided to play well tonight yeah
so uh
battery not play well tonight put it on
e6 and okay after bishop p1 which i
consider it like a poor move uh somehow
photography cc 593 will work every time
yes uh but c5 knight c3 after g4 uh was
known you know completely unclear i
think already who is better and why
because okay my
white squares is very poor and also we
can be free check it protects on d1 so
it never works right let's just put that
on the board uh yeah so also it was sort
of a try to play c4 uh check and d1 is
covered yeah yeah there was a try to
play c4 here uh instead of uh yeah takes
on f5 knight c3
uh takes takes okay checks everything
kirk d7 takes r8
maybe this was the way out but here i
was like i wasn't sure about this
position because i'm still allowed
tonight yeah
and uh well if i don't deliver a mate
maybe i'm just i know maybe i enjoy i'm
also ready so like after after after
rookie won okay there's a queen c one
there's rookie six
uh coming so i mean okay i had
completely no idea what's going on right
uh so yeah here i started like uh you
know trying to get to get some stuff
together which was not simple after you
know you just
uh
after you were absent for i don't know
five months
and here if i was alright maybe g6 is
practically not so
you know not so bad because i mean even
if my king remains uh about some
uh
we want some i don't know g
g and f pawns i mean still i can put my
rook into seven or something so what's a
queen c1 is the move which shocked me a
little bit like photo okay it's time for
him to exchange and get a pawn back and
then try to play rogue d3 yeah but i i
believe we both like played uh
quite you know
you know up and down game yeah which was
admired me you got to this position were
surprised by rook d3 yeah absolutely i
was absolutely surprised i mean i was
shocked so yeah probably i had no reason
for i seen the reason for him not to
take that pawn
i don't think he's like massive rewards
here i'm not sure he's worse at all
i was like more worried if i mean maybe
he's better already but uh okay um
that's
somehow i hoped that you know that's not
as bad and here i thought okay wow i
should be winning already again but uh
yeah the idea he came up with is quite
interesting so here
maybe i have something something
different yeah but in this position
after bishop d2 uh just to no
just one second just to you know
for you to understand the level of uh my
you know
concentration is that i seriously
consider it the move knight c7 for quite
some time 27 yeah but uh i turned it
down not because of queen xc5 which i
spotted like the last moment or because
of like i mean one yeah and it's it's
hard to protect b7 pawn yeah
so that was like uh
that was the player
and you know yeah like uh
at some point i thought okay if there is
like a player in this tournament who is
capable of throwing such position uh
he's basically right now at the board
yeah
uh with black pieces yeah yes typically
yeah to be even more clear but here i
think i found out some some nice plan
like at least i'm losing on b7 and uh in
some in some positions i even try to run
with my king to you know to the center
or maybe my knight so finally i'm
playing uh without denied for i don't
know for a dozen of moves then finally
yeah
playing you know in you know inequal
inequal lineups so okay queen v1 queen
d5 probably he had some options like
rook b3 at some point but yeah rugby
three immediately just were still
thinking it was about zero it could be
but uh i mean okay i had no idea what's
going on
but he was in sort of a time-time
trouble and i don't think he he played
it like
he managed it
so what was the moment that you thought
all right i have brought it all the way
back to winning i think uh after okay
this rook g6 so here's more or less
force to do like this bishop h6 yes and
that's clear without the king of six i'm
just in time i mean it's basically up to
me if i want okay i just move my king to
some you know to d7 c6 but okay then i
get it on b6 so this was a bad idea
i mean theoretically yeah yes but uh
which is
see what seemed to me like more uh
smart like to bring my knight to e6 and
probably with such a setup like 96.5 for
g6
uh it would be like in the worst case
some couple of checks
yeah and that's actually what happened
in the game right no i mean okay queen
h4 if it was the move but after queen h4
uh king of seven i think queen h5
he's somehow trying to play ruger free
here yeah so there is a pin but maybe i
can go for queen e5
and i didn't really see if he makes any
progress because once his bishop
retreats i always have this knight seven
mufa uh unpinning
i mean okay uh maybe also some queen in
two trick will work okay then queen if i
check maybe that this is uncalled for
i mean yeah it was
some some sort of madness but
yeah
i mean very shameful well you wanted to
add the end and
cheerful or not it puts you on first
position here at the sinkhole cup tied
with alareza farouja
how do you feel about your match-up
going into the last round
unpredictable
predictable
anything can happen
it's been a long tour but certainly you
must be looking forward to trying to win
your first singfield cup uh
this would never harm but um yeah i try
to remain realistic here so if i
like keep playing because
today from let's say move 20 to 30 and
probably i can only win some i don't
know
uh what's the game price yeah
so i should yeah i should focus better
well you know we don't have one of those
we do have a brilliancy price we hope
that you are fighting for that one
tomorrow
we'll see we'll see guys any questions
no just uh congratulations and your
co-leadership yan and we're looking
forward to uh not your drifting but your
focus uh for tomorrow we we wish you
good luck in the championship round
thank you yes sir absolutely